(cheerful ukulele music)
- [Narrator] America loves
Leinenkugel's Summer Shandy.
It's the perfect summertime drink.
But have you ever stopped to wonder,
what the heck is a shandy?
- Shandy is a beer, but
it's a beer mixed with
something a little extra.
- [Narrator] That's Dick Leinenkugel,
his family's been brewing beer since
his great-great-grandfather
immigrated from Germany.
So in 2006 when Dick went looking
for the perfect summer
beer, he started by asking:
- What do the Germans
drink during the summer?
Kolsch, Berliner Weisse, Hefeweizens.
- [Narrator] And then he
discovered the shandy.
In Germany they were mixing
beer with something extra.
A tavern owner named--
- Franz Kugler.
- [Narrator] Was running out
of beer during a bike race.
So, he mixed it with lemonade,
and thirsty cyclists rejoiced.
(bike bell rings)
(crowd cheers)
Inspired, Dick then turned
to brewer Jackie Laumann.
- I set out to create that perfect balance
of lemonade flavor with a great beer.
- Voila, Leinenkugel's Summer Shandy.
The first batch was so popular,
Leinenkugel's ran out by the 4th of July.
So, the next time someone
asks you, "What is a shandy?"
You can trace its heritage,
or you can just tell them,
"It tastes like summer."